I have a lot of viewers ask me at one
time or another to provide them with
some sort of list of philosophical texts
or philosophical thinkers sometimes the
very general ideas sometimes they're
more specific like it would be the top
10 existentialist texts that you would
you would suggest me to read and
recently my friend and former classmate
from Lakeland College
Daniel Callahan asked me about a similar
kind of list a top 10 list he wanted one
down to even you know addition and
translation and I'm not going to try to
provide any of those sort of details
here I think I will do that in a
different video but it got me thinking
quite a bit I put off creating any sort
of listing like that in part because
it's very difficult to do I've given a
lot of thought to to the one that I'm
about to give you here and I'm going to
give it to you in the short form and the
long form the top five and the top 10
and these are the top five or 10
philosophical works that I would bring
with me to a desert island if I could
only read these 10 works or these five
works for the rest of my life what would
they be
and this is very different than asking
about if you could only read 10
philosophers anything that you like from
their works for the rest of your life
what would they be because in that case
some of the people who didn't make it in
here would probably make in it like say
Nietzsche or or Kierkegaard but there
are certain works that are great not
only because they're great in themselves
but because they encapsulate a whole
bunch of other viewpoints so when you
read them you are not only engaging with
that thinker you're engaging with that
thinkers take on this thing or this
thing or this thing or this thinker and
I also steer towards the ones that are
more
systematic that have a lot more meat you
could say that are that are elaborating
a huge master argument of some type so
top five I'm going to give you those
first and then I'll expand it to the top
ten so number one Plato's Republic
number two Augustine City of God
number three Thomas Aquinas is so mateal
ogi number four de cartes meditations
and number five Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit so those are the five that I
would take with me if I could only pick
five to read for the rest of my life to
take to the desert island or under the
sea or in to the cave or the bomb
shelter or what have you if I was
allowed to expand it to ten what would I
bring with me this is going to seem kind
of an eclectic list Aristotle's
metaphysics that was a very tough choice
and I'll tell you why in a bit
Pascal's Ponce's and then it's three
what I consider to be really great
classics of 20th century European
thought one of them is probably not a
big surprise to too many people Tigers
being in time and the next two are
probably a little less well known but I
consider them to be equal in quality to
Plato's Republic or Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit or Martin
Heidegger is being in time one of them
is mock sailors formalism and ethics and
non-formal ethics of values and then the
last one would be the guy who I wrote my
dissertation on who I still am very fond
of Maurice blown Dells first masterwork
his own dissertation accion 1883 so let
me tell you why I would
these particular works Plato's Republic
that's that's almost a no-brainer I
think if you put together important
works lists of philosophy this one
almost always makes it in there may be a
few people who want to show how you know
independent thinkers they are when it
comes to Plato they'll put the Phaedrus
or the symposium or the gorgeous or who
knows the protagonist or something like
that in there but most people
acknowledge that that the Republic is
really his his masterwork if there is
any that you want to call Plato's
masterwork and the reason why I would
bring it along is really any platonic
dialogue that I taught and I've talked
quite a few of them in my classes every
time I go back to them I find more and
more interesting stuff that I want to
think about more as a matter of fact my
old great professor who I read the
symposium with over the course of a
semester Rick Williams he had been
reading the symposium for thirty years
and he and say I can't put it down
because every time I come back I've got
new questions and Plato is good for that
because of the way in which he wrote
because of the profundity of the thought
because of his understanding of not just
human nature in general but of types of
thinkers and you you get all of that
here in this work in the Republic I had
a friend who actually taught an intro to
philosophy class just using the Republic
because you've got metaphysics ethics
political philosophy aesthetics
epistemology philosophy in nature you've
got a whole bunch of different things
rolled into it so I don't really care
whether you know using the Blum
translation or not but I I would
definitely include the Republic so
that's that's number one number two
Augustine City of God now you might say
why the City of God and not say the
confessions if it's going to be
Augustine well the city of
God okay it doesn't have the narrative
that the confessions does and I really
do enjoy that that narrative but it's
you know it's got a ton of stuff in here
and Augustine engages with other
philosophers in the course of the
discussions the entire work the city of
God is really a defense of Christianity
as a a system of life a system of
thought as opposed to other ways of
looking at things in response to
accusations that Christianity was
weakening the Roman Empire so August
thing has a huge design in writing this
he covers all sorts of amazing you know
things in here some of it I would say
admittedly is not really philosophy some
of it you know it is clearly straying
you know into into theology but it's
it's really worth reading and rereading
you know like with Plato the more times
you go through it the more you get out
of it so that would take us to you know
the cusp between ancient and medieval
and then you know if I'm allowed to
bring entire books Thomas Aquinas he did
write a book which is available in
multiple volumes called the summit a low
GI and in a way it sort of like cheating
isn't it to say well I'm going to bring
the summit along but it was supposed to
be one unified work maybe you could say
well you can only bring you know one
part of the Samoa law and then I would
have to think about which part what I
actually pick would it be the first part
would it be the first part of the second
would it be the second part of the
second those are the ones I'd probably
you know steer towards the most but I
mean the swimmer is is magnificent in
that it is engaging with practically
everybody who Tom
this had ever read in one point or
another it's a systematic attempt to try
to treat not only Christian doctrine but
everything you could think about that's
relevant about human nature society
metaphysics epistemology and even you
know the philosophy of the emotions
Aquinas is is sort of taking the best of
whatever it is that he comes across from
the Christian world from Jewish thinkers
from Muslim thinkers from from pagan
thinkers and bringing them all together
and trying to think them out in some
sort of unity so it's really a
phenomenal work and you could spend the
rest of your life just just you know
studying the soma and that would be a
worthwhile application of one's time
number four this one's a little bit
different I have the this French version
which I particularly like because it's
got not only the meditations and the
objections the replies but it also has
the Latin below the the French because
originally Descartes wrote it in Latin
that it was translated into French so if
I had to pick a version it would be
something like this I have another
version which which actually has the
Latin and the French facing each other
which is kind of nice why would I pick
two carts meditations the cart is not
doing what I just said that Plato or
Augustine or Aquinas are doing which is
you know sort of engaging everybody else
he's he's trying to sweep everything
away and then rebuild what he's doing is
is still indebted to medieval
scholasticism as Jill song showed in his
early work and there's some continuities
between Augustine and Descartes that are
kind of interesting to look at as well
and I just love Descartes for the force
of his thought I don't actually buy into
his metaphysics but I think it's very
interesting
to think about if I had to pick you know
a viewpoint that I don't espouse to be
the viewpoint that I do his spouse
perhaps it would be that of Descartes so
I know I could certainly read his his
meditations profitably the rest of my
life and when you add in the the
objections and his replies to them then
you get like an extra bonus so then we
come to number five Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit and I've always
you know I've always loved Hegel since I
started reading in every time that I do
the work of working my way through this
massive complex difficult tome I get
more out of it I can't say that I fully
understand Hegel at this point even
though I'm you know teaching this this
online series on Hegel frankly I don't
even know if Hegel completely got Hegel
okay when you come down to it there's so
much here and again you have something
kind of similar to you know it Hegel is
the Thomas Aquinas of the modern age
trying to synthesize all these different
perspectives into one systematic unity
that can actually be comprehended in and
make sense and he does it in terms of a
metaphysics of mind or spirit which
develops dialectically and I really like
that so I I find even though I don't
agree with Hegel you know where he ends
up and I don't agree with his his you
know some of the twists and turns of
dialectic I I would love to be able to
read this the rest of my life so those
are the top five now let's talk about
the the top 10 so we're adding in the
next the next ones and I do have some
Aristotle and this was a very very tough
choice
this is the Loeb edition which has you
know the Greek on the facing page in
English which is which is good because
sometimes Aristotle's Greek is reps care
and you need to actually see what
somebody else had to say about it why
the metaphysics this was this is very
difficult to decide you know why not the
politics or the nikah mccain ethics or
if we have to pick another one possibly
on the soul well you could make a good
argument for any one of those and you
know i actually do more work on the
politics and the ethics and i teach them
more often than i do the metaphysics but
i think that if you only had the chance
to read one work of Aristotle for a long
time this would probably be the best one
to do and it would it would be a real
head cracker because he's you know
dealing with a lot of concepts that are
that are difficult to make sense out of
it does help to have the other texts I
have to say when you're when you're
reading ourselves but I think this one
could could stand on its own and it will
introduce you to things like actuality
and potency or the four causes or what
privation as opposed to you know the
fullness of something is and those are
really worthwhile to think about even if
you can't find immediate application for
them and even if Aristotle's wrong in
his metaphysics it's something worth
grappling with when you tie it in with
some of the other works
you know like Aquinas is somewhat a low
GI and Hegel's phenomenology of spirit
and Plato's Republic I think it assumes
an even greater strength to
that that makes it more worth engaging
with we jump all the way it back into
the modern period and I pick des cartes
great nemesis the one who called him
useless and uncertain 90 the answer that
the guy who said that Descartes brought
it in God just to get his system going
and then left them all over to the side
and that's Paschal sponsees and the
Ponce's are fairly systematic but
they're also somewhat anti-systemic by
their very nature by what they're trying
to grapple with it is a work of
apologetics that that Pascal was never
fully able to finish so it's sort of
like you know Nietzsche's will wilt a
power or some other people's works where
it's it's they're there they're not lost
the works that were left behind that
somebody else had to compile but what's
there is just brilliant and I would love
to read Pascal for the rest of my life
as well so this is this is a work that
I've derived a lot of enjoyment and
benefit from over the course of my
philosophical career now we jump into
the 20th century Martin Heidegger is
being in time not a book that I if you
asked me ten years ago I would have put
in there but it's really grown on me
over time I really enjoy some of
Heidegger's analyses after you get your
way past his weird language that he
comes up with but you know if you can
get through Hegel you can get through
Heidegger in that respect he's got a lot
he's got a lot of really great insights
to communicate he's wrong about some
things I think you know definitely wrong
about about certain things but I think
he's also got some things
very right and this is one of those
works where you're going to get
discussions of other thinkers you know
liked it card or like Conte or like
Aristotle and so that makes it you know
very enjoyable as well my sailors
formalism and ethics and non-formal
ethics of values let's see how thick
this book is it's got a lot of really
great material Schuyler was a
phenomenologist who was a contemporary
of who Cyril and Heidegger and you know
from Chris role and Heidegger you get
one genealogy of phenomenology from
Schaller you get you get another one and
Schuyler was very interested in in value
and in ethics and so he discusses just
all sorts of things you know the
subtitle a new attempt towards the
foundation of an ethical personalism
Schaller thought that person's are what
are fundamentally most real you know
it's a personalist metaphysics and he
just discusses you know topic after
topic at the topic in a very innovative
way and if you could only pick one book
by Schaller because he wrote a lot of
other great books for me this would be
the one and what's great about this is
he's also going to discuss as many of
the other ideas about ethics and value
and in the process about metaphysics and
epistemology and how we understand
things as he possibly can on the way so
he's going to gauge Aristotle he's going
to engage Augustine he's going to engage
Conte he's going to engage even you know
people like Hegel to a certain extent um
the last one somebody by the way who
Schaller invited to collaborate with him
on construed Ian when Schaller was in
charge of it and who turned him down for
a variety of reasons there's there's a
lot to be said there maurice blown dealt
and blown dell wrote a lot of works as
well
blown dell was called the french Hegel
or the Catholic Hegel by by many people
because what he's doing in this and what
he's doing it
other works is very similar to what's
going on in the phenomenology of spirit
he's tracing out this entire dialectical
development you know working from the
bottom level all the way up to the
highest forms of society culture
religion philosophy and trying to you
know do a rigorous analysis from a
essentially phenomenological perspective
he calls it the method of imminence but
it's really a type of phenomenology anti
dating whose role by the way and it's
it's great it's um it's very systematic
but it's not you know it doesn't have
the sort of stultifying problems that
philosophical systems do because
Blondell was very attuned I mean the
books called action and he thinks of
thinking itself
as a type of action and he's interested
in seeing how not our just thoughts
about being you know cause things to be
the way they are he's interested in
seeing when we're acting as persons what
comes out of that and so you know just
brilliant work the this is actually the
translation I would recommend the the
Blanchette translation so those are my
top ten if I was stuck on a desert
island and could not ever get my hands
on any other philosophical works books
that I would bring along in the the raft
the the canoe what would have you and
like I said I had to give a lot of
thought to these you notice that most of
them have a couple qualities in common
they're by top-notch thinkers who you
know just bring brilliance to whatever
it is that there's they're studying
they're systematic they are working out
a rigorous unified conception of things
trying not to leave anything out in the
process they for the most part engage
other thinkers other people other
developments within the
the history of ideas so by reading them
you are getting their take on things but
you are at least getting a take on on
the books that you weren't able to bring
to the island with you and those three
aspects really go into making them in my
view some of the most desirable works to
to have along